how did you book the job on compound
fracture
well it goes back to that first gig that
i got
when i first moved to l.a it was a short
film called everyday joe directed by
shane cole
and it starred jason charles miller as
everyday joe
who's also jason charles miller is also
the lead singer of the band godhead
and
through my interactions with him on that
short
he asked me to direct a music video for
him
for godhead and it was
2005 2006 that i did that video
and i had eric roberts in it so that was
a huge
fun thing for me like coming straight
from ohio like oh man i'm doing a video
with uh
academy award nominated actor eric
roberts i got to direct him that was
really cool
fast forward to years later i'm doing
another music video with jason he's
started a new
he's gone down another path with his
music he's now
done some alt country
and taking his skill set from the
industrial music genre and
brought it over to his passion from his
childhood which is country music he's
from virginia dc area
and
so he's tapping back into that and he
asked me to do another video for him
well in that video he had some of his
friends come and be in the in the video
it was about a bar
and
the time periods that this bar had been
through so i did this video where
basically see the bar in like the 50s
and
20s and
60s and 80s and
then now
and it kind of fades between the eras
and one of the eras was the 80s era and
this bartender
uh the guy that was playing the
bartender was tyler mayne
and he's friends with jason i had i knew
who he was but i didn't know him
personally at the time and
i forgot what was going on on set but he
he was liking how quick i was moving i
think and he had been considering
who to hire to shoot his film compound
fracture that he was going to be doing
and he asked to look at some of my work
and i put him in front of my laptop and
then went back to what i was doing i had
done that a million times showing people
my real on sets and
you know wasn't an unusual situation
so i just kind of let up left him with
it and i went back to what i was doing i
had a lot more there was a ton of people
on set and i had to tend to them
um
as the director and the cinematographer
is a tough one so
he came back to me at some point he gave
me my laptop back and he was like man
that was really cool we should get
together and talk about
uh this movie that i want to produce
compound fracture i was like all right
sounds cool i've heard that a million
times too
so
i thought nothing of it really we went
back to shooting finished the video the
video turned out pretty cool i got an
email from him
um
basically saying hey let's get together
and
talk about this movie and i was
originally at being asked to shoot the
film as a cinematographer
something happened between
when i met with tyler about shooting the
film and a couple weeks later
and they had asked me he'd have said
something's not working out with the
director that i have right now
would you be
interested in maybe
picking up a slack and doing both and i
was like
absolutely
so i went over to his house a bunch we
were planning this film for six months
maybe
and pretty much from that point forward
it was just like
you know i was directing the film and as
part of uh
compensation i would say i was offered
the producer credit as well as a little
bit of uh ownership in the film
and you know
i brought a lot of things to the table
for that i brought
knowledge of equipment and i brought a
lot of
gear deals and friends to the crew and
place you know things like that so
you know it turned it was a benefit for
both of us
and the film
got off the ground somehow in january of
2012.
our initial shooting plans were going to
be we're going to shoot it overseas in a
country called georgia
and we had done months of work on on
getting that prepared we're going to
build the set for the house
and
use all local crew for the most part and
that fell through instead of giving up
we were like what if we just do it here
and that's when everything started to
come together with you know what
resources could i bring to the table
that would make that happen
um and because i've been doing movies
for a while at that point and i was able
to kind of help
coordinate all that and bring it to l.a
and we went to a bunch of location
scouting
and yeah
this kind of just developed from there i
spent quite a bit of time at tyler's
house during the early parts of that
process
i got to meet his wife renee
who wrote the script with tyler
and
yeah it was a lot of fun
i did not expect that some job that i
had done off craigslist
as a 21 year old fresh kid out of ohio
into la would ultimately
bloom into
poss you know doing my first feature
film
on a large scale
so
it's pretty neat how that works but it's
also
kind of like a it was a
affirmation of
the choices that i made
and the
the uh
strategy that i had for navigating
through the los angeles
you know la la land
did you actually write an affirmation
out or it was just a mental no it was
just like a mental thing you know i was
kind of like oh yeah it's
all that stuff paid off you know like
all those choices that i had done early
on
thankful for them because
it ultimately led to
you know you can buy the movie in
walmart and best buy now it's pretty
cool
you